hallo mein name ist programm ich bin
heute endlich mal wieder eine runde
addario nachdem sich das fiel immer
wieder gewünscht hatten habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache heute mal in folge wo
ich mir die besten skins raus mein handy
fängt dann an zu laden ich versuche
einfach ein paar coole skins heute
machst du nehmen und zwar fangen wir an
mit dem skin de da haben wir eine brille
auf
the fucking hallo hier wächst und wächst
und jetzt das die renova das war wieder
so eine übermütige aktion von luca ich
weiß gar nicht wie sich dieses spiel so
lang nicht gebracht habe ist unglaublich
cool es macht mir viel spaß oder sitzt
alle sagen aber ich find's toll und
jetzt erst noch mal hallo eben oder auch
nicht ob ich bin euer idm babys lasst
mich bitte einfach anna vergeht ganz
wenig else ich habe auch schon auf
einigen webseiten geschaut ob sich
möglich ist dass ich irgendwie meinen
eigenen avatar benutzen diesen smiley
allerdings wollte ich mich dann auf
dieser website anmelden und es ging
einfach nicht er kam einfach so ein
fehler
okay es war sie was haben wir denn sonst
noch was deshalb wenn wir schon das kinn
tatsache freunde dieser skin von wales
einfach schwarz
warum mein avatar wird ohne witz richtig
gut in dieses game rein passive ein
bisschen hoch genommen so ein bisschen
quatsch mäßig aber nein den gibt es ja
nicht ok hat einen verdammten schwarzen
skin yes yes und zack da habe ich dich
auf eben schnell gebaut gott jetzt kommt
da hinten dieser türkise man hh blackout
99 du kannst nicht entkommen
ich komme die immer näher du nimmst
masse zu und ich denke wir sind gleich
groß scheiße wir sind hier viel zu viele
große sind wir derzeit auf jeden fall
besser dran als mittel gerade das können
wir auf jeden fall das noch festhalten
man wir sind umgeben von so vielen
leuten was ist denn das mann und ein
tolles auf platz eins achter haben wir
ja die cl von vorhin wieder die wird
jetzt erst mal schön gefressen wenn du
mir nämlich keine punkte gibt es in
diesem spiel
dann kommt ea an und macht aus dir kommt
noch herr jetzt in die cl ich will holen
wir uns eben was soll denn das wir sind
immer gleich groß sache ja wie soll ich
das spiel nicht mehr gespielt habe es
ist einfach so langwierig man man fängt
an und die aufnahme gibt es schon eine
viertelstunde jetzt wieder ein bisschen
action gemacht ttv in einen poller
grande hat gerade versucht mich zu essen
das heißt paula grant ist auf jeden fall
das nächste ziel was angestrebt wird
komm herr kompalla dollar oder daniel
barack obama mit ihr kommen obama
wenigstens was soll denn das sie muss
auch irgendwann fressen könnten und die
langeweile kommt wieder an staats- und
wir fressen
nein ich bin schon so und so und jetzt
fressen wir bagger fressen der poker
face it wird immer ein bisschen action
freunde sah es auch nichts richtiges
kommen dann gehen wir es einfach mal
hier zusammen im iso reihen so uns den
neuen skin raus es gibt tatsächlich noch
ein ganz interessantes gehen und zwar
heißt dieser skin face punch wir sehen
aus wie ein sehr deutsches gewirkt
oh mein gott facebook ist erfolgreich
alter facebook frisst sich hier durch
alles durch ort da ja was ist denn da
fordert würde viele leute papst tut
verdammt was ist euch doch einfach
scheiße wo kann ich denn hin
ohne hier und jetzt kommen den anderen
ja auch noch an ein ach du heilige ich
muss hier einfach aus dieser krake raus
man ich fühle mich da alleine hier drin
wie sind sie denn so viele große
batterie haben wie so ein bauer name
das kind war scheiße dem nächstes gehen
den ich mir ausgesucht habe ist höher
und zwar sehen wir aus wie jemand der
gerade gefressen wurde man was ist denn
das für eine scheiße er die ganze zeit
gefressen von irgendwelchen an jetzt ist
japan schon wieder hinter mir agrio ich
liebe dich aber manchmal hasse ich dich
kluge aus freunde und buben soll endlich
haben wir immer ein kleines wäldchen
gefunden wurde und ein bisschen fahren
können und darauf auch noch dem mister
lobby wieso bin ich eigentlich immer
gleich groß wie alle anderen born eine
gala on ein nein nein addario
verschwindet freunde schnell schnell wir
haben es geschafft wir sind nicht
gestört könnt ihr euch nicht andere
leute suchen die er töten wollt ich bin
noch ganz jung geil scheiß spiel wenn
wir schon nicht richten können hier
irgendwie nicht top ten zu kommen dann
kann es wahrscheinlich unsere
bundeskanzlerin nur noch machen
das kind heißt nämlich merkel das war
glaube ich auch irgendwie klar dieser
troll verfolgt mich schon die ganze zeit
das ist so eine nette wäre ja auch meine
fresse als ob man dann keinen stil mir
irgendwie